from reality TV Queen to Fashion Mogul
Kim K is no stranger to our feeds we
know the inner details of her family
love life and business ventures largely
thanks to her leading role in the hit
show The Kardashians and while Kim is no
stranger to tabloid drama the world had
a legitimate fit when she showed up at
the 2022 Met Gala in Marilyn Monroe's OG
dress some fans loved the look others
found it offensive I'm sure she knew
that that was going to be par for the
chorus but what I'm not sure she
anticipated was the dumpster fire
response to the insane three-week crash
diet she used to lose 16 pounds for the
dress so today I'll be attempting to eat
like Kim Kardashian and unpacking the
dangers of her controversial Met Gala
diet hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
to Abby's kitchen
foreign
[Music]
I'll be putting Kim K's Met Gala diet to
the test but you all know the drill I'll
be dressing everything up Abby style and
turning into hunger crushing combos that
I actually want to eat big time because
y'all know I have no interest in
starving or even weight loss a quick
disclaimer that this diet was compiled
from primary and secondary sources so I
really can't speak to the accuracy of
Kim's actual diet really doesn't matter
here folks I'm not making any kind of
claims here because I'm only using these
alleged meals as a template for teaching
gender nutrition and for inspiring what
I decide to make for myself this is just
what I ate on a random day and is not
meant to be copied or recommended as how
you should eat always speak to a
registered dietitian about your unique
needs okay let's first discuss the dirty
Deets on Kim's controversial Met Gala
diet so Kim lost a whopping 16 pounds in
three weeks leading up to the Met Gala
which she claimed to achieve by cutting
out sugar and eating low carb protein
and veggies this also meant that she had
to transition from her usual mostly
plant-based diet to eating more meat in
order to accommodate these restrictions
and despite this strict eating regimen
both Kim and her personal trainer
insisted that she lost the weight the
healthy way without starving herself but
is there any way losing five pounds a
week can be done in a healthy way well
first of all it's not uncommon to see
rapid weight loss with low carb diets as
immediate declines in glycogen dries up
our water stores which results in a
quick result on the scale but around
five pounds of that first bit of weight
loss will likely just be water not fat
to lose four and a half pounds in a week
you're looking at a significant calorie
deficit and combined with Kim's intense
workout regimen it would be likely
impossible to meet her overall nutrient
needs the other risks for Kim
specifically is for her psoriasis Kim
told or that eating more meat on this
diet caused her psoriasis to flare up
and even resulted in psoriatic arthritis
which made it very painful for her to
move her hands and while psoriasis
triggers are highly individualized we do
have some research showing that the
arachidonic acid in red meat May trigger
psoriasis symptoms in some folks so it
makes sense that Kim credits following a
plant-based diet for helping to relieve
her psoriasis symptoms and that eating
meat to accommodate these weight loss
diet rules caused her a lot more pain I
mean it's sad to me that she would
jeopardize her own well-being to the
point of pain and physical impairment
just to wear a dress for a few minutes
but I guess everyone's values will
differ and while she may be considered
this transformation a success even
likening it to the genius of extreme
body transformations in movies Matt Gala
or Nomad Gala movie or no movie
dangerously rapid weight loss diets
should never be replicated with that
said I will not be produced
participating in a no sugar extreme
weight loss diet but I will be taking a
look at what Kimmy usually eats in a day
and dressing it up Abby style so Abby
what's for breakfast I like Kim alright
but first coffee so according to Twitter
Kim typically goes for a small soy chai
latte or the smallest size white
chocolate mocha with whipped cream both
of those sound amazing but both are
pretty high in sugar so probably not
what she was choosing to drink during
the Met Gala prep personally I really
dislike super sweet cloying coffee
drinks I just kind of like like my
coffee straight up with milk so I gotta
find a weight Infuse some chai flavor
without the cloyingly sweet syrup so
that way I at least enjoy it let's do it
soy milk we got
soy milk is typically how I like my
lattes too as you can see I need to open
another container all right a little
more
great and Ivy chai tea
bag chai tea tea bag
tea bag
I'm just going to let that kind of steep
there to let some of the chai flavors
Infuse into the milk
okay while we're waiting for that let's
get a shot of espresso down
in My Cup
seems appropriate
and hot
I think this should be in a simmer but
we are getting some tea seepage action
this is a really big pain in the ass I
can totally understand why someone just
wants to like
pump in a few shots of the chai flavor
because yeah who has time for this maybe
someone on Kim's team but I'm a
one-woman show here making her own
goddamn coffee and I'm gonna say that's
good enough for me
sorry
oh my God it's on the camera me this is
hot oh and it like literally burst my
frothers pieces of from Amazon
whatever all right guess that means it's
time to pour
okay gotta finish this off
do you want to wipe yourself all right
just gonna finish it off some extra chai
spice a tiny bit of Ginger not too much
or it's going to be really weird a
little bit of cloves also just a hint
and some cinnamon that was a little over
zealous but
good enough
let's give her oh she's hot
it's pretty good I mean way too much
work to pull off for coffee but since
it's here I am definitely gonna drink it
yes
all right now let's get something to eat
so if you are a regular Kardashian
viewer you probably are familiar with
the Kim K chia pudding Kim Kardashian's
being spotted like once eating chia
pudding and suddenly it's like her
recipe now as far as low carb recipes
goes like I don't hate it but Abby
what's the deal on Gia so chia seeds are
loaded with protein fiber and omega-3
fats making them a three in one hunger
crushing combo they also have a unique
capacity to gel in liquids so they're
often used as an egg replacement in
baking or to make a pudding as we're
going to be doing today okay so full
disclosure I cannot get over the texture
of traditional chia seeds like the ones
in Kim's chia pudding my kids also hate
them and will not touch chia pudding if
it has those like globules in them
anyways so my little hack is to buy
white ground chia seeds not only do you
not get that little like little all
texture in your mouth but it also gels a
lot faster because they've been ground
up so you don't have to like wait until
the next day let's let's take some chia
pudding I'm going to try to measure so I
don't this up for once but anyways here
we go I'm gonna do like three quarters
of a cup of milk again I'm using soy
milk so we got some extra protein here
I'm gonna do like a quarter cup or so of
Greek yogurt
we've got six tablespoons of our chia
seeds here one two three four five six
good A little squirt of maple syrup to
taste
now this is basically where Kim's recipe
stops but I'm good hunger crush and
combo it and I'm gonna add some
chocolate so I've got some peanut butter
here I mean I don't know why I'm
measuring this this is just kind of like
what I want or we've got a dirty Dove I
guess we need to use it now
okay and a little chocolate I mean I
never really know
how much it's going to take to add the
chocolate flavor but not make it taste
like you know
tastes like chalk I'm already choking on
it just like inhaling the fumes okay I'm
going to start there and we can always
add more let's get
the blade on and you can just stir this
together but if you puree it again it
gels faster and everything gets
Incorporated a lot nicer
just gotta check for chocolate
consistency
I think we can add a little more a
little more cocoa
and a little more maple
great
and you know what
this like you know
go big or go home that's what I say
might as well just add that in there
foreign
got some berries some peanuts and
some chocolate chips
all right let's recap we've got protein
in the Greek yogurt the soy milk and the
chia seeds plus all the nut butter and
nuts we've got lots of healthy fats in
the Chia nuts and peanut butter and a
lot of fiber in the Chia plus all the
berries on top this looks really good to
me and in all honesty a huge upgrade
from like the globularly white and black
plain chia pudding I've seen on the show
no offense
hmm
so much Barrel
okay so I've admittedly watched the
entire season of the Kardashians so I've
seen Kim spend a lot of time in her gym
and according to Kim's trainer Kim was
spending up to two hours a day in a
sauna suit in the weeks leading up to
the Met Abby
should probably take a pass right yep
well sauna suits have quickly become a
popular Kardashian endorsed workout
accessory we actually have no research
to support their use for fat loss all it
can do is temporarily make you lose
water weight which you can easily
replenish when you have a drink that
said the research that we do have on
sauna suits suggests that they are
dangerous as increasing the risk of
dehydration heat exhaustion heat stroke
and possibly death in 1997 for example
three Collegiate wrestlers died from
heat stroke and cardiac arrest after
using sauna suits to help them qualify
for their weight class the scary part is
that the students followed an eerily
similar weight loss regimen to Kim by
working out for two hours in the suit
while restricting calories this tragedy
ultimately led to the National
Collegiate Athletic Association to
completely ban the use of sauna suits
for weight loss so just another reason
to approach celebrity endorse weight
loss tips with Extreme Caution so yeah
the sauna suit the two hours in the gym
and trying to fit into clothes that
don't fit my body I'm all about
exercising to celebrate my body and make
it feel good not punish myself and try
to make my body smaller but yeah
unfortunately it is kind of on brand for
the Kardashians to push a lot of
dangerous weight loss tactics without
considering the impact it may have on
their very large audience one thing I
can get behind though is little cardio
and strength training sesh so I got
about 20 minutes before I got a hop and
a call let's do it
[Music]
thank you
all right folks let's talk lunch it
would not be a Kardashian day of eats
without a nod to Kim's famous chicken
salad
eating a salad with us and just shaking
a salad
I think I've made a phenomenon about
shaking salads I mean the salad should
really be racking up royalties at this
point because of how many cameos it's
had okay so I did a little bit of
digging and found out that the
Kardashian Clan gets their salads from
HealthNet in La we've heard of that
place before and Kimmy's favorite is the
Chinese chicken salad basically it's got
shredded chicken chow mein noodles
Pickled ginger and a sesame dressing
which sounds amazing to me and I would
say technically this salad would be like
met gal approved if we left out the Chow
Mein noodles but I feel like that's the
best part am I right so yeah I'm keeping
the crunchy nudes let's make salad
I'm just gonna like
try to shred this a little bit more
finely
without killing myself
because this is salad not rocket science
here folks so it doesn't need to be
perfect
all right we got some crunchy cabbage
which I just love
got a carrot Shredder up
carrot
it's a lot of work a little more
I'm gonna add
some of these
instant noodles
crunch them up
you can also just like buy a Mr Noodles
it actually really hurts my hands this
is definitely not something that Miss
Kim whatever
subject herself to
and then I kind of like to like get the
crunchy noodles mixed into the veg
because otherwise they get too crunchy
and like they feel raw they need to like
soften them up a little bit like
marinate them just a tinch just a tinge
I just made that word up yes I know
don't come at me okay that's a good
starter let's try to clear the board
here
we're in struggleville's today my
friends okay all right got a little
green onion
some other whites
and the light green
I have a very small avocado TBD if it's
going to be good or not let's see it
does not feel promising
um I feel like that's usable so I it's
pretty soft but not rotten
would have been a great guac avocado but
we're gonna make it work that's
canned mandarins
I got the tape I think this is no sugar
added yeah this one's just oh natural
just the mandarins I think in some water
throw that in love that I like a little
extra because I love the mandarins I've
got some shredded rotisserie chicken
that's some great protein there I've got
Pickled ginger this is one of my like
favorite salad additions
so good
yum
like lots in there I could just eat a
salad a pickled ginger and I feel like
get some of those juices in there that's
gonna also add a lot of flavor yum
that'll do let's get that avocado in
Boop I'll just kind of like mix it in
it'll almost be like part of the
dressing because it's definitely a
softer Avo but she's adding lots of
healthy fats so we love to see it last
but not least some crunchy peanuts and I
got some dressing this my friends oh I
forgot to put the
green onion in folks green onions going
down adding flavor all around I don't
even like her dancing at like yeah
um okay let's get the dressing down
foreign
this is Mandy's salads uh they're Sesame
vinaigrette which is I think very
appropriate in this situation all the
dentists who watch me are going to be
like Abby you don't use your teeth or
anything
love that
a little bit of that and now it wouldn't
be a Kardashian salad
without the shake
this smells delish guys I'm genuinely
excited about this okay so we got lots
of fiber in our veggies plus our fruit
and our avocado in there we got carbs in
our noodles and our fruit healthy fats
in the avocado plus a dressing and the
Sesame and we've got our protein in the
chicken I mean this looks great
hear that crunch
all right it is 3 P.M and the afternoon
slump is hitting hard so I'm feeling
like meat a little afternoon pick me up
so Kim hit Twitter back in 2020 to talk
about how much of a fan she is of sea
moss smoothies apparently because of
their alleged anti-inflammatory
properties Abby I'm not super
enthusiastic about the idea of having
like moss from the sea in my smoothie so
yeah are there any like real health
benefits that make it worth choking that
down well I mean I guess it depends
on your flavor standards but it is true
that CMOS is rich in anti-inflammatory
antioxidants which may be beneficial for
folks with autoimmune disorders like
psoriasis so I can see where Kim may be
going with this in addition to being
rich in vitamins and minerals we also
have some research showing that seaweeds
in general May benefit our gut health as
they are rich source of fiber and live
bacteria however you're looking at
around 30 to 40 three dollars a jar for
CMOS and while this amount is like a
drop in the bucket for a billionaire
like Kim K for most of us we're probably
better off just like eating any other
accessible fruit or veg yeah I'm gonna
pass on the CMOS and I'm just gonna whip
up a smoothie using anti-inflammatory
antioxidant rich foods that I already
have on hand I got some berries frozen
banana for some sweetness handful of
frozen kale Greek yogurt
loads of hem Parts some nut butter
and as much milk as I can possibly fit
in Lord help me
I mean we probably put in as much
nutrition as humanly possible and I did
it for a lot less money than buying a
jar of that SEMA so Bottoms Up
um
and a taste bomb
all right we finally made to dinner and
I'm pretty excited to wrap up this day
so our girl Kim is apparently a fan of
tacos like who isn't we all love a good
taco but so much so that she has her own
YouTube tutorial and push article
sharing her favorite plant-based recipe
so yeah I'm excited about this I'm not
going to make it fully vegan just like
looking at all the ingredients here just
because like I like regular cheese and
regular sour cream and that jazz
um just don't love dairy-free cheeses
don't come at me but otherwise I'm like
totally on board and excited to make
this recipe so let's do it
all right a little avocado oil down and
I got some Beyond beef oh she leaking oh
my God gotta go wash the old hands all
right let's just start breaking this bad
boy up
and the recipe calls for a bunch of like
individual spices but I just have a
fiesta time taco seasoning here which I
think is just gonna do the trick and
make my life a lot easier not a lot of
that all right while that's cooking
let's chop some veg
okay so the recipe calls for some
ketchup uh I have my kids veggie ketchup
by the way this stuff is actually really
amazing for recipes because it's just
made of vegetables anyway so I really
like that oh oh no
oh let's go there I got more a little
bit of that action also calls for Agave
I don't have agave but I got honey so
I'm gonna use a little bit of that just
to sweeten it
some water
oh
just let those flavors come out smells
really good
[Applause]
delicious let's build some tacos
I got some guacamole going down
let's pack it in with that really yummy
taco meat
gonna add in some Tomatoes a little bit
of shredded cabbage
some cooked corn here
a little dollop of sour cream
obviously you can make that vegan if you
want
and I love a little feta hit
finish it off with squirt a lime
that's a taco all right let's recap so
Kim apparently uses like keto tortillas
I don't eat keto obviously so I went for
a nice whole grain tortilla for some
extra fiber also lots of fiber and the
guacamole and the extra vegetables that
we added on top we got protein in the
vegan beef plus lots of healthy fats in
the avocado and some extra fat with the
cheese and sour cream as well you can
veganize that if you want now to attempt
a bite without it getting all over my
face
hmm
that's so good all right we have made it
to the end of the day and I am very
excited for another little bedtime snack
so other than the CMOS smoothie which
let's be real I would not be so happy
about if it was the last meal of my day
Kim also allegedly loves to snack on
Oreos Cheetos cheese puffs and Doritos
all super delicious options in my books
I have to assume that those were a No-No
on the Met Gala diet prep but I think
we've already established that I've
thrown those rolls at the door and I'm
feeling like little Sun sweet to end the
day so Oreos it is
yes sure I could hunger crush and combo
this but why mess with a good thing I'm
just gonna do my Oreos the old-fashioned
way with the little Kim K twist I got my
soy milk for Duncan and my Oreos for
eating very important question are you a
full dunker a Twist and dunk like what's
your Technique this may offend some
people but I dunk the half with the
cream and I saved the other half for
like baking
um
it's hard to accept a cookie without
cream when you've already had one that
has it
[Music]